[Music]
hi
mystery recapped here today i am going
to explain the drama romance film called
the terminal spoilers ahead watch out
and take care
[Music]
the movie begins with a man named victor
navorsky arriving at new york's john f
kennedy international airport victor is
from a country in eastern europe called
krakogia he is in the u.s to fulfill his
lifelong dream of visiting the big apple
however the man can't speak a word of
english at the airport victor discovers
that his passport is no longer valid and
as a result he is pulled to the side by
the airport security victor is also
penniless because his country's currency
is no longer a legal tender in the u.s
u.s customs and border protection
officer judge thurman seizes his return
ticket and passport and takes him to
frank dixon the acting field
commissioner of the airport dixon
attempts to tell victor that the u.s
government doesn't recognize krakojia's
new government after a military coup
plunged the country into a civil war
while victor was in the air victor is
not permitted to either enter the u.s or
return home as his passport is no longer
considered valid however dixon feels
sorry for him and allows him to stay in
the international transit lounge until
the issue is resolved dixon hands victor
some food coupons a calling card and a
pager before sending him off to the
lounge bad at communicating in english
victor fails to gain entry into the
lounge and gets stuck at the terminal
there victor who didn't understand what
dixon was telling him about the military
coup finally learns about the crisis at
home through the images and videos on
the television seeing his home in crisis
victor breaks into tears he pleads with
other passengers to help him call back
home but everyone ignores him however
victor's bad luck doesn't end there and
he somehow manages to lose his meal
vouchers dejected victor settles in an
old and run-down baggage section of the
airport with only his luggage and a
planter's peanut can it's not as good
company as wilson the volleyball but it
will do
victor who seems to have an unusual love
for the peanut can uses his diy skills
to make himself more comfortable
meanwhile dixon's boss richard announces
his retirement and informs him that he
is slated to take richard's place as the
active field commissioner if he gets the
approval from washington dixon is elated
to hear the news and richard advises him
to not mess up the inspection process
dixon is confident about his promotion
but he suddenly remembers a problem that
could derail his promotion namely victor
the next day victor spends his entire
morning standing in the visa line in
hopes of getting a visa but to no avail
the visa officer dolores torres tells
him that he can't get a visa without a
passport dixon keeps an eye on him
hoping to catch him breaking a law so he
could have victor arrested and get rid
of him however victor stays within the
confines of the airport and the law
making dixon regret helping him
determined to get victor out of the
airport and make him someone else's
problem dixon schemes to get victor to
leave the airport by ordering guards
away from a pair of exit doors for five
minutes victor takes the bait and almost
leaves the airport but he notices a cctv
camera tracking his every move and he
grows suspicious he eventually figures
out dixon's ploy to get him arrested for
illegally entering the u.s so he decides
to stay in the terminal when he isn't
bothering visa officer dolores victor
spends his time learning about new york
and american culture he slowly becomes
good at communicating in english and
starts using rewards for returning stray
shopping carts to pay for his food he
also helps a flight attendant named
emilia warren catch her flight on time
he develops a crush on her but only to
see her kissing another man you haven't
truly been introduced to the big apple
until you've been cocked dolores also
starts developing empathy for him after
having encountered victor so many times
dixon learns about victor's tactic to
buy food and deploys a man to stop him
from using the reward system seeing
victor eating biscuits at lunch airport
food worker enrique cruz approaches him
cruz offers to provide victor with food
in exchange for victor's help in getting
torres to go on a date with him victor
accepts the offer and spends the next
few days helping crews understand
dolores likes and dislikes victor learns
about dolores ex who cheated on her and
warns cruz against breaking her heart
again the thought that don't cheat on
her is advice that some men need to hear
is cringe one day victor's pager beeps
and he rushes to meet dixon dixon tells
him that he has found a way to get
victor out of the airport he tells him
about a provision in the u.s law which
allows an illegal alien who has a
credible fear of returning to their home
country file for asylum after explaining
everything to him dixon asks the man on
record if he has at this time any fear
of returning to his country however
victor answers with no he seemingly
didn't understand what victor explained
to him and says that he can never be
afraid of his home later victor again
encounters emilia talking on the phone
with her boyfriend she is having an
argument with him as he stood her up
seeing her cry victor goes to comfort
her the two talk for a while and amelia
asks if he'd like to join her for dinner
but since victor can't leave the airport
he reluctantly refuses the offer with
his broken english he tries to make
amelia understand about his situation
but she simply thinks that he's not
interested in her an embarrassed emilia
then leaves him next we see victor
visiting different shops at the airport
asking people for jobs but since he
lives at the place and has no contact
information or a dress no one takes him
seriously one night a board victor
starts working on an unfinished wall and
completes it overnight the constructor
contractor is stunned by his skills and
immediately hires him victor finally has
a job which pays 19 an hour even by
today's standards that's good money one
day the inspection team visits the
airport to check the day-to-day
operations as usual dixon tries his best
to impress everyone as he is desperate
for the promotion suddenly a foreign man
is seen causing a problem at the customs
office he has some medicines with him
which he doesn't have documents for
dixon finds out that the man is from a
country near krakojia so he calls victor
to ask as a translator in exchange for
this dixon promises to help him get out
of the airport victor then talks to the
distressed man and translates that the
medicines are for his father dixon
however says that the man will have to
provide legal documents if he wants to
take the medicines out hearing this the
personnel detain the man and confiscate
his medicines victor suddenly feels
sympathetic towards him and lies that
the medicines are for his goat and not
his father he then says that he had made
a mistake while translating dixon
immediately realizes victor's intentions
he knows that he's been reading forms
about the us rules one of which states
that documents for animal medications
aren't required despite dixon
threatening victor that he won't help
him if he's lying victor stands by his
statement that he made a mistake in the
translation the stressed man also plays
along with this claim finally after
having no evidence the officials
reluctantly release the man a furious
dixon then grabs victor by the neck
meanwhile dixon's boss witnesses
everything leaving his chances of
getting promoted very slim the next day
local sweeper gupta tells everyone about
how victor helped the stressed man as
his act of generosity is spread across
the airport he is respected and loved by
everyone later victor goes to dixon's
office and apologizes to him for making
him look bad but dixon is unmoved an
angry dixon then says that as long as he
is in charge of the airport victor will
never leave
next we see victor with the help of his
friends finally ask amelia out for
dinner amelia gladly accepts and the two
head for dinner at a spot inside the
airport victor's friends have redesigned
the place to look like an actual
restaurant at the dinner while the two
of them are conversing amelia describes
how she is fed up with her life she
complains about how her life is just
about going in and out of the airport
and that she wants to live freely victor
says that his life has been stuck in a
similar way too however he doesn't
disclose about his situation after a
wonderful date amelia finally leaves and
the duo plan to meet again in 13 days
meanwhile victor successfully helps
enrique he and taurus become very close
and eventually get married victor also
starts working on something which he
plans to show emilia as a surprise after
13 days amelia finally arrives at the
airport but when she is about to meet
victor she gets called by dixon as he
has seen her being close with victor
dixon asks her to get more information
about him he also wants amelia to find
out what victor always carries in his
can finally he reveals that victor has
been staying at the airport for nine
months shocked amelia says that he's
almost beaten mr beast's record and she
feels that she has been lied to at night
an emotional amelia meets victor and
discloses that she was about to break up
with her boyfriend as she was starting
to like him as she tries to go away
victor stops her saying that he wants to
show her something he then takes her to
the place where he was building
something and uncovers a beautiful
fountain which he made from broken
plates he knew that emilia is fond of
napoleon so he built a fountain exactly
like the one napoleon built for his wife
josephine to further show his love he
opens his mystery can and takes out an
old picture of a jazz group he says that
his father is a big fan of the group and
that he had sent each of them letters
after waiting for 40 long years he
managed to collect signatures of every
member except one as emilia gets
emotional victor says that the one
member who didn't send back the
autograph is benny goldson but his
father died before he could add the
final piece to his collection however
before his death victor made a promise
that he would get the signature and
complete the collection hence he
traveled to america to fulfill his
promise victor continues that in order
to meet benny he will wait as long as he
has to he will also wait for amelia
since he loves her moved by his
selflessness amelia gets up and kisses
him one morning victor's friends arrive
and notify him that the war is over in
his country a delighted victor then
starts celebrating with the people at
the airport emilia also arrives and
victor tells her the good news she gets
emotional but at the same time is very
happy for him emilia then hands over a
legal document with the help of which he
can get out of the airport for one day
he can now visit new york and get the
signature of benny goldson however
victor's happiness turns into
disappointment when he finds out that
the paper was managed by amelia's
boyfriend who is a powerful government
official she eventually decided to stay
with him but before leaving she wanted
to help victor victor then heads to
torres and hands her the travel pass
seeing the pass she at first gets happy
for him but eventually realizes that the
document has to be signed by none other
than dixon victor then reaches dixon who
instead of signing his paper hands him
his passport and tells him to leave
america victor replies that he will only
leave once he can visit new york dixon
opposes this and blackmails him by
saying that if he doesn't leave he will
deport his illegal friends back to their
respective countries without hesitating
for a second victor agrees to leave
america for the sake of his friends as
he is leaving the airport his friends
try to stop him but he ignores them he
then meets a furious gupta who calls him
a coward for not rebelling against dixon
despite this he continues his way out
without telling gupta the reason for his
departure then an officer finally
reveals why victor is leaving without
visiting new york at the office dixon
seems relaxed and he has finally gotten
rid of victor once and for all but his
happiness is short-lived as gupta is
seen trying to stop the plane in which
victor is heading back home he isn't
scared of getting deported back to india
as he wants victor to fulfill his
father's dream meanwhile the flight to
krakojia is officially delayed until
further notice victor can now finally
leave the airport as he moves towards
the exit everyone rushes to see him off
they provide him with gifts and wish him
the best for his journey as dixon
witnesses this he orders the guards to
stop him exiting the airport at this
point only the guards stand between
victor and new york dixon then tells the
guards to arrest him officer therman
then tells victor to turn around as
everyone anticipates victor's arrest the
officer covers him with a jacket instead
saying that he'll need an extra layer
since it's snowing outside victor
finally steps out of the door after an
excruciatingly long wait of nine months
he then takes a taxi and leaves to meet
benny just as he leaves dixon arrives
outside when asked if he wants to stop
victor he simply replies that he is
tired of all this and is in fact
impressed by his sheer determination
victor has won dixon over dixon on the
other hand is still a complete jackass
victor arrives at a jazz club and
finally meets benny goldson he asks him
for the autograph but benny suggests he
wait a bit an emotional victor then
hears the group perform something which
his father would have loved after the
performance victor gets the autograph
and completes the collection which his
father started 40 years ago he can now
finally return back to his home country
in this movie victor spends a total of
nine months at the airport but meiran
karimi nasseri the man whose life
inspired this movie spent an astonishing
18 years at the charles de gaulle
airport in paris
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching